A video you haven't seen before.
Pictures of a hero taking mass murderers
gun away.
Confronting, grappling with him
and disarming
someone who had just moments before
shot and fatally wounded.
11 people at another location
and was about to do the same again
Saturday night at a ballroom
and dance studio
in Alhambra, California,
just outside Los Angeles.
Brandon Tsay and his family run
the video is slowed down somewhat.
The man in the frame is the 72 year
old mass killer
who had already carried out a mass
shooting at another ballroom
in nearby Monterey Park.
Now, the weapon
he's carrying,
according to authorities,
is a nine millimeter Ingram Mac
ten semiautomatic
with what appears to be a suppressor
or a silencer.
Which authorities say he'd
been making at home.
Brandon Tsay tells us he
heard sounds metal on metal noises.
And you can see the shooter
pulling back on the weapon
and then for a few seconds,
he withdraws into the doorway
as if to look around, at which point.
Seconds later, you see Brandon,
they're entering and confronting the man,
his arms outstretched,
reaching for the man and then the weapon.
The struggle then moves into the doorway
and just outside that room.
We're just seeing this
for the first time.
You've never seen this video before.
Brandon will describe in a moment
just what was happening,
what he was doing
and thinking in the seconds that we see
and what we don't see.
Again, the killer has a Mac Ten,
apparently a suppressor in stock.
He'd already killed ten people.
An 11th victim died today
and he might have taken many more lives.
Had the scene we're watching played out.
Otherwise, had Brandon
not gotten the gun
and driven
the gunman who later took
his own life away
We're going to be
joined shortly
by the congresswoman
who represents Monterey Park in Alhambra.
But first, my conversation
with Brandon Tsay.
I spoke to him just before airtime
Brendan, first of all,
you've been through so much.
How are you holding up
Well, I'm
doing way better
than I was at the night of the incident.
So can you just take me through
what happened on Saturday night?
Okay.
So Saturday night,
it was a Chinese New Year,
the Lunar New Year.
It was felt like a casual night.
Very typical.
We had our customers
coming in and out
for our social dance party.
I was in the office
lobby most of the time.
It was late into the evening
when the incident occurred.
When did you know to Sheppard sound
high?
When I knew something was happening.
I heard the sound of the door
the front entrance shutting.
And then there was a sound, a distinct
sound of metal
coming together
as if it was being rubbed together,
like someone was moving metal on metal
And how far away was
that sound from you?
It was no more than two meters away.
So did you see the person then?
No.
What alerted me was a sound.
I only turned after I heard that sound.
What happened then?
After that,
I when I saw what I saw, I froze up.
The man had a gun
The man was Brant and Brandy and a gun.
He had a gun pointed at me.
It seemed like he was trying
to scout out the room for other people.
Was he saying anything?
I mean, you're saying he was
two meters away.
So that's, what,
about six feet away from you?
He was pointing the gun at you
the whole time,
or was he moving it around
It was in my general direction,
but when I saw him,
it was pointing straight at me, and
he was trying to look for other people.
Looking at the scouting room.
And he didn't say anything at all.
He was silent, even stoic, very scary.
That he wasn't even saying anything
or giving me any instructions.
And so what happened
What happened
was it seemed like
he was preparing his weapon to fire,
changing
some sort of setting on the gun or
fixing his gun to prepare to fire.
That's when I sprang into action.
I realized
in the moment
that I needed to do something.
At this moment,
I need to grab the gun,
try to disarm him so
he couldn't do any harm to me or others.
So in that thought, I mean,
not a lot of people in this moment
would have maybe thought
to run away or to dove for cover.
Your thought was to
get the gun
Oh, yes.
I'm not going to lie.
I did
freeze up when I saw him with the gun.
I had many thoughts where I would think
I'm going to die.
This is it.
This is the end for me.
But then something happened.
You know, something came over me.
I just had this rush of thought
and adrenaline, you know,
in this sort of situation.
And I was able to come to a conclusion
that I needed to do something.
I needed to grab the gun and saved myself
and the people inside.
And you're talking about
all these thoughts you had.
I assume this is all happening
within split seconds in your head.
How long were you standing there
looking at him, seeing the gun before you
you acted
No more than 2 seconds.
I saw a window of opportunity
that he was distracted with his gun
and took it.
I took him to action
once I saw the opportunity.
So what exactly did you do
I made sure that nothing
was in my way to
attack him.
And lunged at him with both my arms
and grabbed his weapon with both my arms.
And were you immediately able
to take it out of his grasp?
know, there's a big struggle, actually.
The struggle went on into the lobby
He hit me several times
in the face behind my head.
With what?
With his hand back.
He was with his hands.
He was trying to feed me away
from his gun
while trying to gain
control of his weapon.
But at the same time,
I was trying to divert the weapon away
from me,
away from the ballroom
and down on the ground
in case he did fire
and that
I was also trying to free from his grass
and using my elbows, using my shoulders,
trying to use my body way
to free the weapon away from him.
And how long was this struggle for
I would say
the struggle lasted
40 seconds, but it felt like way longer,
felt like an eternity with the adrenaline
and my thoughts.
I was always thinking about
if I let go of this gun,
what would happen to me?
The people around me,
my friends, my family, how would they
be affected
if I let this dangerous
individual run around and work?
Were you saying anything to him
during the struggle?
Was he saying anything to you?
No.
We had no verbal
threat.
We had no verbal conversation.
But he seemed like he didn't
want to talk from the start.
It seemed like
he was trying to take action instead of
have any type of
conversation or commands.
So you said it
went on for 40 or so seconds.
And then what?
Then what happened?
How did you finally get it away?
Well,
as he was trying
to attack me with his arm and his hands,
I used the opportunity to
yank the gun away on his office
opposite side
so he wasn't able to fully
use his strength
to keep the gun in position.
And that's when I was able to
pull the gun away from him and
create some distance
between him and the gun
I had.
Have you ever had you ever held that?
Go ahead.
No, I have never held a gun before.
It's scary to even the weight of the gun.
It's haunted on me how this object was
something that could end
in a person's life.
So you have the gun and you
create some distance.
Did he did he run away then?
No.
At this point,
he looked like
he was still trying to fight.
But I pointed the gun at him
and told him, go go away.
You got to leave. Go get out here.
And I also threatened him
that I would shoot.
And
I had many thoughts
I thought I would
actually have to kill him
as actually shoot a person.
Were you prepared to do that?
Yes, I was prepared to fire,
but I didn't want to shoot him anywhere.
That would be fatal.
I wanted to see if I could
aim at the legs or the arms, you know,
something that would stop him from
trying to cover the gun.